كان الأمل الأردني وربما
الإسرائيلي في ذلك الوقت هو أن يؤدي ذلك
إلى حل شامل على
مستوى المنطقة وسلام دائم
وكل هذا للأسف لم يتحقق أي من
هذا ، لذا نعم اليوم نحن
في أدنى مستوى.  مستوى
العلاقة الذي كان منذ
توقيع معاهدة السلام هو أن معاهدة السلام
معرضة للخطر
بشكل جيد ، حيث يمكن لمعاهدة السلام أن تدخل في
وضع التجميد العميق ، وبالتالي قالت إنها
معرضة للخطر بالتأكيد ، فإن
رؤيتي تقدم فرصة مربحة
للجانبين  حل الدولتين الواقعي
الذي يحل مخاطر
قيام الدولة الفلسطينية على أمن إسرائيل ،
أعني أن المظالم الفلسطينية هنا في
هذا البلد الأردني هي قضايا داخلية ،
أليسوا قلقين من
أن هناك ثمنًا يتعين دفعه مقابل عدم
دعم تلك الصفقة من خلال مواجهة  إن
الضغوط الاقتصادية من الولايات المتحدة التي
تزود الأردن بالطبع بمليارات الدولارات
من المساعدات الاقتصادية.
لقد كان الأمر كذلك
مع جميع أعضاء الإدارة الأمريكية في
مجلس النواب الأمريكي ومجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي والشعب الأمريكي ،
فنحن لسنا قلقين من أن تلك
العلاقة الاستراتيجية ستتأثر ،
هل ناقشت الولايات المتحدة معك
تفاصيل هذه الخطة التي تتضمن بالمناسبة
بعض المشاريع المحددة للغاية  أن الأردن
لن يستفيد من أي من
عناصر هذا الأمر قد تمت مناقشته مع الأردن
قبل إعلانه ، ولن
نخلط بين التطلعات السياسية
والصفقات المالية التي تواجهها
مهمة صعبة موازنة
المانحين الدوليين وهم السكان المحبطون
ديون الأردن نسبة الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
عادلة  أقل من مائة بالمائة ،
معدل بطالة أقل بقليل من 20
بالمائة ، وهو أعلى معدل خلال 25 عامًا ،
أنت تقول إن لديك خطة ،
فما لدينا هو خطة مدتها خمس سنوات من
شأنها أن تضع اقتصادنا على مسار مستدام
نظرًا لكل ما نتمتع به  لقد
ورثنا بالطريقة التي أوصلنا بها إلى
هذا الوضع السيئ للغاية حتى نبدأ
بإغلاق الحدود أزمة اللاجئين
التي أعقبت العرب  إن
سوء الإدارة والفساد في
الاقتصاد هو الذي أوقعه في هذه الفوضى ،
وهو سؤال مشروع لدينا ،
فقد أنشأنا جميع المؤسسات اللازمة
ومنحها كل
الاستقلال للنظر في
قضايا الفساد ومحاربتها ، لكن إذا نظرت إلى
العدد الهائل ، فأنت تعلم  تكلفة
الانقطاع بسبب الغاز المصري
تكلفة استيعاب 1.3 مليون
لاجئ سوري أي 20٪ من سكان الأردن ،
هل يمكنك أن تتخيل دولة
تستوعب 20٪ من سكانها
بين عشية وضحاها وتبقى تعلم أنها قادرة على حل
ما يقلقنا هو
نفاد صبر الناس  ونحن نتفهم سبب
نفاد صبرهم لأنه مرت 10 سنوات
على الركود الاقتصادي بعد
اللاجئين السوريين والوضع الإقليمي برمته
والبطالة تتصاعد
البطالة بين الشباب ومن
الصعب جدًا إقناع
شاب أو شابة مبدعة متعلمة  قل حسنًا ،
هل يمكنك الانتظار لمدة أربع أو خمس سنوات أخرى ،
ما يحدث للاقتصاد سيكون له
تأثير على الأوراق المالية في الأردن  إن
استقرارها واستقرارها أمر
مهم لإسرائيل وحول هذه المنطقة
الكثير من حلفاء أمريكا ، ما مدى
قلقك يا سيدي لأننا نعيش في منطقة مضطربة
ونحن في
الطرف المتلقي
لهذه المشكلة منذ اليوم
الأول والأردن  أصبحت مرنة للغاية على
الصعيدين السياسي
والاقتصادي ، فليس من قبيل المصادفة
أننا رأينا دولًا بحجم عشرة أضعاف
حجم الأردن وعشرة أضعاف اقتصاد
الأردن ينهار ويتحول إلى
دول فاشلة للأسف لم يكن الأردن
السبب هو وجود
بالتأكيد أقول إن الثقافة السياسية التي
تطورت في الأردن حيث
يتحد السكان من نواحٍ عديدة
نتفق مع هذا الرأي ، لكن هناك
وحدة وراء الحكم الهاشمي في هذا
البلد ، حاولت العديد من الخطط الضغط على
إسرائيل للانسحاب من منطقة حيوية
مثل وادي الاردن لكنك سيد.
أيها الرئيس ، أنت تدرك أن إسرائيل يجب أن
تكون لها السيادة في وادي الأردن ،
فأنت تعترف بسيادة إسرائيل
على جميع المجتمعات اليهودية في
يهودا والسامرة.
خطة تشكل تهديدًا
وجوديًا للأردن ونعلم أن هناك خطابًا
من اليمين الإسرائيلي كان
يلمح إلى
نقل سكاني نهائي للفلسطينيين إلى الأردن.
أتفق بالطبع مع هذه
التصريحات حول الأردن هي فلسطين أو
أن عملية النقل هذه
خطيرة للغاية وليست طبيعية فقط
بالنسبة للأردن ،
بل إنها تشكل خطورة على المنطقة بأكملها
بالنسبة للاستقرار وما إلى ذلك ، لذا فهي
تلعب بالنار حقًا
في  المنطقة التي هي بالفعل في
وضع مضطرب لذا فهي تدفع الأشياء في
الاتجاه الخاطئ ولا يمكننا إلا أن
نعارضها تمامًا  إد